ملف اشباه الموصلات يعود مجددا للواجهه في
الولايات المتحده التي تعتبره جزءا من
امنها القومي اداره الرئيس جو بايدن تعتمد
خطه جديده لتعزيز سلطه الحكومه الفيدراليه
على هذا القطاع الخطه تقضي بان مصنعي
اشباه الموصلات في الولايات المتحده
والذين يسعون للحصول على شريحه تقارب
اربعين مليار دولار من الاعانات الحكوميه
سيحتاجون الى توفير ظروف افضل لعمالهم
اضافه لمشاركه بعض الارباح الزائده مع
الحكومه وزيره التجاره الامريكيه جينا
ريموند قالت ان القواعد الماليه ستشجع
الشركات على طلب التمويل الذي تحتاجه فقط
وسيمنعها من تحويل اموال دافعي الضرائب
لملئ جيوب مساهمها الاداره الامريكيه كانت
اقرت العام الماضي قانون اشباه الموصلات
الذي خ 52 مليار دولار
لتوسيع تصنيع وابحاث اشباه الموصلات في
امريكا على امل جعل البلاد اقل اعتمادا
على الموردين الاجانب للرقائق الالكترونيه
في وقت لاحق اغرى احتمال الوصول الى هذه
الاموال صانعي الرقائق المحليين والاجانب
للاعلان عن خطط او البدء في انشاء مشاريع
جديده في اريزونا وتكساس واهايو ونيويورك
وولايات اخرى كما ذكرنا اداره بايدن
تتعاطى مع اشباه الموصلات ضمن نطاق مفهوم
الامن القومي سواء من الناحيه العسكريه او
تلك المدنيه ايضا وبالفعل يعتبر الرئيس
الحالي اكثر اهتماما بهذا الجانب من
اسلافهم
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده تواجه معضله تكمن في
تخلفها النسبي على الصعيد العالمي في هذا
المجال في وقت يزداد فيه الطلب على
الرقائق بينما الانتاج لا يوازيه على
الاطلاق نيويورك تايمز نشرت تقريرا حول
مصنع تي اس ام سي التايواني اكبر منتج
لاشباه الموصلات في العالم واشارت الى
شكوك الموظفين بشان استثمار الشركه هذا
مبنى
لبناء مصنع بمبلغ اربعين مليار دولار في
ولايه اريزونا الامريكيه الصحيفه اجرت
مقابلات مع احد عشر من موظفي الشركه
وقالوا ان المشروع الجديد يمكن ان يصرف
الانتباه عن التركيز على البحث والتطوير
اشار الموظفون الى ان البناء في الولايات
المتحده مكلف باربعه اضعاف التكلفه في
تايوان مدفوعا بنفقات العماله والتصاريح
ما قد يضر بربحيه الشركه هذا العام
كما تحدث البعض عن القلق بشان كيفيه دمج
مصنع اريزونا بين الموظفين الامريكيين
والتايوانيين لصعوبه توحيد الممارسات بين
الموظفين في الدولتين او من الدولتين
والتوقعات بان العمال التايوانيين
سيتحملون مسؤوليات اكبر من زملائهم
الامريكيين
[موسيقى]